At the back of one of the most a cheers of
anime in the past decades 2019 has some
big shoes to fill and you know what I
don't know if that's gonna be possible I
mean just look at these weak-ass choices
promised Neverland sounds stupid mob
mob psycho one hundred season - yeah like the
first was any good you know there just
Anything worth getting excited over.
I am back.
I am ready.
So what better way to start with Kakegurui XX
and its only two X because
this isn't porn
yet
What can I say just more of the same gambling goodness agai-
As I was saying its more of the sam-
So I am gonna do you a favor and give you a little background behind Boogiepop because
I went to this show completely blind
and what i got from episode 1 was pretty much
Huh? What? Heh? Alright? Who?
I am sure this will make sense.
WHAT?
But it was only after reading up about the series and watching in the
next few episodes did I actually get it.
Boogiepop is kind of like a supernatural mystery
show separated into different arcs
The thing is we are shown events out of
chronological order. The first episode
for example gave me the beginning and just jumps
straight to the end of the story arc.
It constantly feels like you are piecing together a puzzle
as you are slowly drip fed information piece
by piece which makes no sense individually
but as you get more pieces
Michael here well this means is that we
have an anime romance that progresses
even slower than usual meaning you're
probably result in them holding hands
and around 10 trillion years or so but
it's so extra and I fucking love it it's
original it's entertaining it's funny
and now everyone's freaking out over a
raccoon girl this season but I think we
may have accidentally discovered the
solution to world peace in chica and the
stance which has consumed my soul and is
the greatest achievement of mankind in
human history right Michael
I'm alone
well that is that show constitute open
said number one in C major
wah banger dialog is pretty much where
the art comes in taking some words that
someone has just said holding them in
your hand and then punching them in the
face with it because that would
definitely be the fucking title of this
show are you ready to go on a fucking
journey with me cuz this first episode
was a fucking journey all right so this
guy normal high school student has a
massive crush on his teacher on one day
he just randomly sleeps with a girl he
met at karaoke you know standard love
triangle premise we've all seen it
before then we find out that his dad is
getting remarried and the person he's
getting married to is the mother of his
teacher and the girl he slept with
that's right ladies and gentlemen you
think you're watching a standard romance
drama shows and bam they hit you with
one of these surprise motherfucker yes
we've got a classic case of the surprise
incest but you know what this show is
just too spicy to pass up it's so spicy
I'm gonna be rating this using the
fucking Scoville scale cause the most
important question is if you want some
spice in your life do you choose your
boring standard not related by blood
sister or do you go with a more mature
also not related by blood sister who's
also your teacher and I think there's
only one way we can answer this but
I'm a teacher and you're my student
why are you so okay with this hey guys
hope you enjoyed that video just before
anything else I do want to give a quick
shout out to Brooke Walker as they do
have a lot of the source material on
their website which includes domestic
girlfriend Verizon with the shield hero
kakigori
and boogie pop in fact they are doing a
kakigori campaign right now we can get
bonus items for every purchase you make
when you use it you can use coupon code
gig up for five dollars off anyway thank
you also to Robert's hardball basil
Patrick Madison now Ken and everyone
else on my patreon for helping to
perform e for this month and making this
video possible now I don't have too many
other updates let's say you know what
I'm just gonna keep this short and sweet
and leave you with the best moment of
this season so far yes you can enjoy
chicas dancing one last time so you know
what how to see you guys next